[Musique]
bonjour à tous Aujourd'hui j'ai le grand
plaisir d'être à Jouy-en-Josas à la
fumerie du coin je vais vous présenter
un artisan fumeur qui s'appelle
Eric barnou
Eric barnou bonjour Véronique comment ça
va ça va très bien et vous ça va merci
bah je suis ravie d'être là merci de
nous accueillir on va vous découvrir
vous votre travail les produits que vous
proposez que vous transformez on est
notre dans votre laboratoire boutique
exactement et vous avez aussi pardon des
points de vente au marché de Versailles
marché de Notre-Dame marché Notre-Dame
donc ici on est sur la partie donc la
fumerie
la fumerie du coin on a voulu mettre un
laboratoire voilà ouvert
aux gens on a une petite boutique à
également ici visuellement ouvert pour
que les voilà il y a une espèce de
transmission une honnêteté avec la
clientèle pour qu'il sache que c'est ici
qu'on prépare tout ce qu'on peut
proposer
j'ai envie de revenir un tout petit peu
en arrière Eric parce que vous c'est
votre deuxième vie exactement vous avez
fait effectuer une reconversion vous
étiez quoi avant alors j'étais
commercial donc dans un secteur
absolument pas dans la dans
l'alimentaire et la gastronomie voilà ça
c'est une passion la fumaison que j'ai
depuis très longtemps avec des amis
ouais tout à fait ouais mon frère on a
aimé les bons produits et les travailler
nous-mêmes donc voilà du poisson de la
viande également en fait maison avec
plein d'autres choses alors je crois
savoir que déjà petit vous aviez un
fumoir dans le jardin
20 ans on a commencé c'était c'était
quoi que encore je suis papa et maman
donc ça d'accord
peaufiner nos techniques après j'ai eu
la chance quand j'ai décidé de
me reconvertir d'aller voir un artisan
fumeur qui exercait depuis longtemps en
Normandie à Granville qui m'a voilà qui
m'a accepté quelques jours dans son dans
son atelier et ça a été voilà que
quelques jours mais très très important
c'est là vous avez peaufiné votre
formation exactement
et alors vous êtes lancés à combien de
temps dans cet aventure 2017 donc ça va
faire 6 ans si je calcule bien
donc ici la fumerie a joué-en-josas donc
on a monté voilà tout ça de nos mains on
est dans un lieu où sont d'autres petits
entreprises
par la mairie de Jouy-en-Josas où on est
voilà une on est cinq artisans voilà sur
différentes différents domaines pas
forcément alimentaire d'ailleurs mais
exactement voilà après on va aller
travailler
on va juste donner un peu une idée de ce
que vous proposez et bon le saumon fumé
classique racontez-moi comment sur le
saumon voilà c'est un incontournable
voilà les c'est vraiment un poisson qui
s'y prêtent très bien nous on a décidé
de passer sur des poissons de qualité
uniquement on travaille sur du Label
Rouge écossais et du bio irlandais un
petit peu sur du français
on est sur de l'élevage alors voilà
c'est un parti pris voilà les les
populations de saumon sauvages sont pas
en très en très bonne forme
on est également sur des produits qui
sont comme la rareté entraîne la le coup
on est sur des produits voilà très cher
donc on a pris une partie de proposer
ces produits là de bien les choisir et
également de faire découvrir aux gens
d'autres poissons sauvage un petit peu
moins connu en tout cas en fumaison et
qui sont voilà qui peuvent être vraiment
excellents alors on est on les prend la
plus dans la majeure partie du temps des
pêches des pêches responsables
raisonnées donc on peut on va proposer
des hors saison des coquilles
Saint-Jacques fumés françaises on a des
sardines des macros fumés là on a
dernièrement fait venir du mulet noir
fumé donc qui est pas un poisson voilà
qui a une personne qui vient du côté de
la Gironde Bordeaux
oui donc vous essayez de proposer des
produits moins onéreux de aussi bonne
qualité
et il y a beaucoup d'autres choses voilà
des poissons qui viennent peut-être un
petit peu moins loin
pêcher qui participe à la à la filière
aussi de la pêche française petit bateau
etc donc euh
qui nous tient à cœur exactement et vous
avez aussi quelques produits transformés
je vois des rillettes
de saumon fumé qui sont voilà qui sont à
tartinés et qui sont superbes du gravlax
on a du gravlaxon c'est un saumon mariné
donc c'est le cassonade quelque chose de
confit très très gourmand on fait de la
truite aussi de la truite fumée qui
vient d'un copain qui est
Haute-Normandie d'une petite boîte
familiale qui fait des tweets
magnifiques voilà c'est pas grave etc
bon bah génial on va on va aller
travailler avant j'ai oublié de dire que
l'édition 2023 itinéraire de
savoir-faire yvelinois vous avez été de
récompenser reconnu repérer en tant que
honneur c'est la première édition c'est
la chambre des métiers des Yvelines qui
a monté ça avec le département
la cérémonie a eu lieu avant-hier si je
lui dis pas de bêtises voilà donc ça
fait très plaisir donc vous êtes reconnu
comme artisan saint label qui s'appelle
label artisan du tourisme donc c'est
mettre en avant voilà des savoir-faire
l'artisanat évidemment des artisanats un
petit peu un petit peu d'exception
donc pas seulement dans la gastronomie
également dans
[Musique]
le sens large voilà donc vous vous êtes
par exemple quand un touriste arrive à
Versailles ou ailleurs il peut trouver
ça exactement voilà je vous invite à
aller voir sur le site de la Chambre des
métiers ou vous avez une description des
33 labellisés il y a vraiment des choses
exceptionnelles dans tous les domaines
j'ai pu les rencontrer lundi soir voilà
c'était très enrichissant également pour
moi personnellement donc aller voir sur
le site de la Chambre des métiers vous
aurez il y a un site spécifique sur ce
tous ces artisans
et apprécié alors maintenant on va se
déguiser enfin je parle de moi on va
bosser un petit peu alors on y va à tout
de suite
allez j'aurais tout fait je vais la
garder
je vais bientôt rentrer au bloc
opératoire la chambre est stérile nous
avons un gros cas aujourd'hui
vous allez me filer un petit coup de
main déjà pour bien comprendre le voilà
on reçoit nous du poisson frais là qui a
directement des cosses d'accord donc je
vous parlais du Label Rouge en fait
c'est des poissons qui sont élevés très
correctement et on a une vraie
traçabilité sur les poissons
ils viennent etc alors je confirme ils
ont bien des nageoires ils ont des
nageoires ils ont une queue exactement
et il ressemble véritablement à des
poissons
qui sont pas trop gras ils sont gras
comme il faut comme on attend du d'un
bon saumon on va les trancher là dans
une grosse semaine
donc on enlève le maximum de d'impuretés
qui peut y avoir à l'extérieur voilà la
brosse bon là ils ont déjà été rincés et
on va les laisser toutes les étapes
suivantes en fait on va avoir ensuite
donc lever les filets les parés on va
saler les poissons
ils vont être fumés uniquement demain
donc à la ficelle vous les étapes après
et ils vont affiner maturer pendant 5 à
6 jours
[Musique]
le filetage des saumons donc important
de le faire faire sa correctement pour
avoir le moins de perte possible et
avoir des filets très très propre voilà
pas troué les roues de toutes ces tâches
quelle est votre tâche préférée
qu'est-ce que vous aimez le plus faire
je pense que c'est cette partie avec le
poisson et le j'ai voulu faire ce métier
pour la diversité de ce qu'on peut faire
dedans
qui restent à gauche on en fait quoi là
moi je vais récupérer la chair
pour ça va me servir pour mes rillettes
on perd le moins possible après la
carcasse
pour le moment je suis en discussion
pour pourquoi pas faire des fonds de
poissons mais j'ai pas encore de
solution pour en faire des sous etc
exactement
la peau alors on a commencé à faire des
tests de tannage mais oui c'est pas si
simple
vous avez deux trois personnes qui font
ça qui font ça en France avec le saumon
déjà
la peau de raie qui est même on peut le
faire avec du bar avec plein d'autres
choses ça peut être très joli c'est un
savoir-faire
magnifique donc vous avez un beau filet
qui est pas troué on l'a pas tordu etc
c'est important important pour la suite
et là il va partir en chambre voilà en
attendant la salaison il va partir
derrière exactement
[Musique]
ça
attends
donc maintenant la salaison donc c'est
un sel qui vient de basse sur mer c'est
une petite coopérative de Sonic qui
viennent de là-bas qui est pas trop pas
trop humide qui est parfait pour nous
donc là l'idée c'est de on sait pas très
longtemps nos poissons
et on essaie de répartir le sel donc
vous avez je vais te montrer je te le
fais en entier tu vas voir l'idée c'est
d'aller vraiment saler les parties voilà
les parties épaisses on sature pas en
scène voilà tu vas juste retourner le
mettre dessus pour pousser un petit peu
le sel super ça suffit c'est bien
très bien
une bonne poignée de sel et puis voilà
c'est votre première
pas trop chargé en sel les côtés
[Musique]
la suite c'est voilà plusieurs heures de
salaison une fois rincée du sel ils vont
partir à la fumaison de lendemain donc
les saumons ils sont fumés à la ficelle
vraiment vraiment à l'ancienne il y a
pas mal de choses qui fait que c'est
c'est le meilleur fait maison en tout
cas pour ce que moi je veux faire et ils
vont nous à la suite affiner pendant les
cinq six jours toujours à la ficelle
donc ça permet de voilà de répartir
correctement la fumée dessus de l'étirer
les chair de les attendrir etc
ils ont fumé pendant plusieurs heures
alors on est pas sur des très grosses
fait maison nous on est sur quelque
chose de très délicat c'est vraiment
adapté à ce que les gens d'ici veulent
c'est ça c'est ça davantage
[Musique]
ça sent bon la fumée qu'est-ce donc
comme
ici donc on est on dépasse pas des
températures au-delà de 22-23 degrés
quelle voie de mettre donc c'est assez
traditionnel sur le sur le poisson fumé
qui est pas trop forte nous ici donc on
veut pas des fumées trop fortes sur le
poisson
de métal est à l'intérieur donc là on
passe par des boîtes donc c'est le
métier de faire de la surprise de
qualité de vos qualités de forêt
exactement
on passe à la partie tranchage donc nous
ici on est sur du tranchage tranchage au
couteau
[Musique]
les côtés risquent d'être un petit peu
trop salé fumé donc voilà on les enlève
alors on sait jamais si quand on mange
du saumon enfin moi je ne sais jamais si
la partie plus brune entre la peau et le
ça se mange ou pas alors ça se mange
j'en fais plein de bonnes choses mais
voilà c'est beaucoup moins intéressant
d'un point de vue gustatif très bien
vous essayez de suivre le web vous
suivez la pente du poisson
c'est un peu chiche
normal de tous les artisans ou pas mal
de temps pour maîtriser pour maîtriser
ces gestes donc il y a quelqu'un qui a
un truc moche là je m'excuse
alors
Eric le fumeur de saumon merci vous nous
avez livré quelques uns de vos secrets
mais pas tous mais on a déjà bien
compris la fabrication de vos produits
donc comme on disait au départ vous avez
différents produits il n'y a pas que le
saumon dans la vie voilà ici vous pouvez
accueillir du public tout à fait on est
ouvert ici du mardi au vendredi de 15h à
18h30 voilà vous pouvez venir récupérer
tout tous les produits puis discuter
avec nous on échange un petit peu et
puis on nous retrouve sur le marché de
Versailles sur le carré le carré bio des
producteurs les vendredis et dimanche
matin donc de 8h à 13h vous nous
retrouvez sur le marché en extérieur
voilà bah écoutez on viendra vous voir
moi je vous remonter à billets très bien
c'était chouette et
attendez on oublie un truc la ferme de
Richard tout à fait c'est une ferme en
aquaponie où on va vous emmener très
bientôt et il se trouve que Richard et
Eric collabore font des tests ensemble
tout à fait justement avec avec les
poissons évidemment exactement alors
déjà vous avez un bel exemple qui m'a
apporté hier je travaille avec lui me
fournit la ciboulette et l'aneth que je
vais mettre dans mes rillettes de
poisson donc qui sont ultra fraîches
très douteux c'est super et puis on va
essayer on fait des tests sur ces
poissons qui commencent à avoir des
belles tailles pour les voilà pour les
fumées et éventuellement je vais vous
montrer mon a déposé hier donc vous
allez voir ça fera le beau lien voilà et
là c'est des on va vous avez
un esturge il travaille avec des
esturgeons merci des esturgeons et
détruites donc assez traditionnelle sur
la truite et l'esturgeon et là on a un
super on a des super poissons qui ont
été là en début de semaine vous en avez
déjà fumé ouais on a fait un premier
test qui était plutôt concluant sur
l'esturgeons et là on est sur une voilà
une vraie belle un vrai beau poisson de
bonne taille donc on va voilà on va
tester tout ça et puis peut-être que
vous les retrouverez en fumaison chez
lui
merci
Eric on va vous quitter et merci à vous
d'être passé travail sur la planche
exactement voilà alors merci en tout cas
pour cette belle découverte et à très
vite et à très vite à bientôt au revoir
Véronique au revoir
[Musique]